vous en tant qu'avocat ou qu'il est au
kick auxquels ils adhéraient votants
quel regard vous avez été choqué par
cette lourde peine huit mois de prison
ferme alors tous tous ceux qui ont été
choqués leur entourage évidemment d'un
point de vue c'est que moi je suis pas
je veux dire je ne suis pas dans le mon
rôle à la place où je suis né pas de
commenter la nécessité de faire en sorte
d'obtenir le plus rapidement possible la
libération de bram ysl mais il ya une
demande de mise en liberté qui est faite
lundi prochain l'appel a été fait
aujourd'hui ça sera jugé dans trois
semaines un mois on verra après les
questions et éventuellement de de la
détention si jamais cessé maintenu voilà
quelques années mon rôle le maroc est un
pays souverain il est son système
judiciaire off comme le nôtre un degré
d'appel
donc on va aussi faire en sorte de
recadrer les choses d'avoir plus
attestation de deux coups de d'éléments
de contextualisation
moi je suis pas ici est donc un
commentaire serait très malade ma part
pour tenter de faire pression sur sur la
sur la justice que j'ai entendues alors
cette histoire on en entend parler je
vous le dis depuis des jours et des
jours je vous dis même moi on m'a appelé
je vous dis on a appelé tous ne m'a
appelé aussi pour essayer de que je
puisse joindre le roi du maroc pour lui
demander voilà si on était sept à terre
si on pouvait faire quelque chose voilà
c'est quelqu'un que j'ai rencontré deux
fois extrêmement sympathique mais bon
j'ai dit j'ai je vois là je ne peux pas
intervenir là dessus c'est qu'ils ont
demandé à plein de comique français
aussi d'intervenir des gens qui le
connaissaient est ce que des gens peut
essayer d'intervenir au plus haut sommet
c'est ce qu'on m'a dit et qu'apparemment
vraiment ça passait pas pour l'instant
la justice alors ils abordent ce qu'ils
ont en tout cas ça n'est pas ça n'arrive
pas ça n'est pas ma démarche d'accord
voilà et moi je sais que c'est pas votre
démarche ne m'intéresse pas que vous
allez pas forcément de 2,2 de brahim
voilà tout ça qui essayait de voies de
fait l'idée c'est que je coordonne la
défense nadal aurait pas d' initiative
malheureuse de peau de propos vous
imaginez bien qu'il ya aussi des
journalistes qui s'intéressent je suis
venu ici avec l'idée que ce soit ma
seule intervention et que vous
consommerez faire à cela voilà pour
comprendre certaines c'est pour ça que
j'apporte cette clarification donc à ma
connaissance en tout cas ce n'est pas
quelqu'un qui serait chargée de la dlep
de la défense est ce qu'on a demandé à
l'état français d'intervenir ou pas du
tout et peut-être de demander son
transfert
voilà les alertes et d'abord de la
situation c'est légitime
j'ai été alerté donc aux lions étaient
c'est normal de faire et ensuite au
niveau à marrakech le consulat il ya eu
un soutien consulaire absolument
remarquable il a été deux fois deux fois
en prison
il songe et voilà où là on a aidé à
faire en sorte que la soeur de brahim
puisse aussi se dépasser voyager
jusqu'au maroc
vous imaginez la difficulté par ces
temps de pandémie dont qu'ils ont été
absolument présent ensuite se posera
éventuellement la question du
transfèrement mais c'est ça mais qui ne
peut intervenir c'est à dire donc de
l'exécution de la peine en france dans
des conditions où la peine se
substituerait à peine français se suit
sur est donc bien sûr marocaine des
choses sauf qu'il faut que la peine
prononcée soit définitive donc il faut
attendre pour l'instant on a fait appel
à nous faut attendre les trois semaines
là comme vous avez dit il faut attendre
l'arrêt de l'arrêt d'appel
est-ce que vous avez ce poids qui
sortent dans trois semaines
bah oui mais j'ai bien sûr j'ai nommé
jeux géants quoi qu'il arrive à celle de
la volonté je me bats pour qu'il sorte
donc là quoi qu'il arrive ils vont
passer donc trois semaines en prison
encore nous ont fait une demande qui a
examiné lundi
il ya une possibilité qu'il sorte